[Music]
Brendan Schaub
on The Breakfast Club
uh Brandon's job I knew I I didn't even
change around black people yeah let's go
so here we go Papa
um I this is one that I will say I have
not seen yet it was sent to me
um
I am going to
I'm I'm thinking that he's gonna do
start talking a little more urban
I think Brandon's going to be a little
more urban what do you think yeah he's
gonna he's gonna he's gonna black it up
a little bit okay so he's not gonna talk
like Delia okay I think at some point
he's gonna mention the soul food that he
likes you think he's gonna take hot
sauce out of his purse no I think he's
gonna mention how he likes watermelon or
fried chicken or something really
[ __ ] really really dumb you only try
yo yo I'm also developing a thick boy
Hennessy
oh my God Brendan
[ __ ] starts doing the voice turns out
I have an inward pass Ed
don't don't do the voice Brendan don't
do the voice here we go now why'd you
leave MMA get into comedy uh I don't
because I got knocked the [ __ ] out I got
literally punched into a different
career I like to hit in the face anymore
and it's just literally what he said
yeah
it's a better living man for me this has
been well yeah all you have to do is
really simple it's a Better Living being
a comic all you have to do is be Joe
Rogan's friend yeah it's safe so why
don't you please do that hey the comedy
will come later the comedy will come
later girl grow into your comedic career
what's most important is you get a
Showtime show
passed your mind for a long time so
um you know MMA UFC's a tough go man
that's a rough go how did you get in the
comedy though like did you because you
ain't funny you ain't funny dog I ain't
gonna lie to you I watch your standards
yet
you would just do like a Mexican voice
for like 50 minutes dog like what's that
about
yeah like how'd you get into comedy
because you ain't made me laugh once
yeah I mean seriously like I laugh at
your knockout compilations every time
you've been knocked out and [ __ ] but
like I saw your stand up and like what's
pico de gallo
beat somebody's ass yo my aunt likes you
but it ain't cause your comedy should
just say you got a cute ass and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
when they were on the floor like how did
you get there it doesn't seem like they
match they don't match at all no they do
they both they were both done by a brain
dead guy I was doing when I was fighting
the UFC I was doing a podcast with a
comedian actor named Brian Callan
well
well kind of can so mean him would do
that twice a week and it started to gain
some ground and then you know it's a
bigger show as far as a podcast finding
the kid and I don't know I just always
wanted to do it and then he was like
this is amazing why do you hate black
people Brenda
what's wrong with black people man
that's crazy isn't that the lazy or just
criminals
that's amazing
start doing the road like coming out
soon that interview's coming out very
soon live podcast and so he would open
up every show with me telling like a
story for like eight minutes he's like
you're just gonna do a story I was like
all right cool man and then uh my
stories were really boring and people
were laughing at them but they were
laughing at me but I didn't get that on
the count of the CTE in the brain and uh
yeah I thought I was really funny
probably a year after that he was like
uh you got your set tonight I'm like set
he's like yeah you got your step your
your stand up I'm like no I'm just
telling a story he's like no I just told
you uh stories
because I didn't want you to be scared
you're doing stand up I was like oh damn
and then we started to do all these live
shows around the nation then I would
give anything to watch his first
stand-up set we did one at the comedy
store in Los Angeles and that's where I
live and then
The Comedy Store this yeah well
basically at least in the F-150 Raptor
outside in the parking lot
um
and I'll tell you where I'll tell you
where his dick lives and whatever the
opening chick's [ __ ] mouth is
um this is um
this is not the the Brennan that we're
seeing I Was Wrong by the way I'll admit
I thought he was going to do more urban
stuff he's not this is a
I'm scared Brendan this is Brendan out
of his controlled environment right
Brendan
can survive in a controlled environment
right but the law has to be like his
friends all kind of you know running you
know protection for him it has to be all
the all the Papa's a nice cops Papa and
all that stuff and he could be out of
his environment like another person's
podcast as long as he is the bigger
person in that in that scenario and he
could kind of alpha mail them but but in
here he is like being like yes Brian
Callan he is this actor
um please don't judge me uh please don't
call me a hunky
uh The Comedy Store like three weeks
later I was like yo we'd love for you to
do a set in the belly room uh Wednesday
night 8 P.M Harley tried to walk into
the building with him and they just like
security stops and was like no he
recognized you from the 50s head show
you just stay out here buddy hey Mark
hey Mercy Mercer hey merch I have a
question for you
would the Charlemagne
from 10 years ago ever allow a pride
flag in his Studio
oh God no God I'm asking maybe he's
changed because I've heard some other
stuff he said about other people too I
think he just likes the paycheck like
everyone else that's kind of weird right
that that uh that Charlemagne's wow he's
really opened up his heart
nine o'clock show at the belly room and
showing it's like what's the belly room
is that like the room where DMX and Nas
hang out in
commit crimes and [ __ ]
room so there's the main room there's
the or and then the belly room is like a
smaller room buddy are you at a hospital
the belly is the belly room where they
took you for your hurt TomTom and the or
is that the operating room
where people start out and so uh I text
them back and went oh let me check with
Brian Callan if he can do it you could
just see Brian
I'll let you know they're like no also
Brian Kellen is a big name drop bud no
he's like no let me let me check with
Brian Cowan that's what he has to say at
The Comedy Store because anytime he goes
let me check with Brian they're like
Brian who
Reagan no no no no no no they go oh
Reagan he's coming that's awesome no
it's gallon oh all right yeah it's fine
[Laughter]
oh dummy just you we want to see if he
can do stand up so that's my first set
and it was off to the running yet how
was the first thing he was off to the
running
he was off to the running first set and
it was off to the running after the
races you're Off to the Races that was
the first set
terrible terrible you bombed bombed in
front of all my friends all my friends
showed up like wow how is that different
than anyone of your podcasts or what
you're doing right now
or your life in general
I mean I'm trying to understand because
wow my first set I bombed is there one
where you haven't done bad or poorly
because cutting together five [ __ ]
20-minute sets to make one 20-minute
YouTube video doesn't really fill me
with hope you know do you understand
remember when Louis CK after he got
canceled and he was just working rooms
like and somebody secretly recorded his
set
Louis CK's secretly recorded set from an
iPhone where some of the jokes didn't
have punches up with a notebook he was
working on them
is five infinitely billion times funnier
than five of your sets stitched together
in some sort of in some sort of
Frankenstein CTE comedy special
the only thing with more jump Cuts than
your [ __ ] comedy special is a [ __ ]
Biden pre-recorded speech or a Philip
DeFranco explaining why his red rocket
news thing was a scam
Chris Delia Cowan Sasso Bert Kreischer
all these people who I emulate
uh all of them showed up did they laugh
or they didn't want to piss you off
no they were like I thought that was fun
man that was cool yeah and then they're
not your friends any okay I have to ask
a question
you probably know a little bit more
about this than me in general but
are L.A Comics completely different
breed than New York Comic like in every
way because because when he just because
he just said well when I was up there
like oh no that was really fun man
do you understand that at one point
Patrice O'Neill threw a phone book at
Kevin Hart when he was starting out in
comedy and said call anybody in there
they'll be funnier than you that's right
oh my God and His guy's over here like
no you did all right man even though you
bought you coddle him because he's Joe
Rogan's friend
that's not up there yeah you knew yeah
thank you for effort yeah it didn't go
well you know they were probably texting
each other during like I don't know no
they're probably hell yeah yeah he's not
gonna do this yeah you get more
adrenaline before a fighter before a
comedy show dude this actually does feel
like a Jesse Lee Peterson
I swear to God I was about to say that
yeah I was about to say that so yeah how
you like doing comedy oh it's pretty fun
that's amazing
uh before a fight is more like hey man
I'm happy we got Jesse Peterson and
fluff a few times and that's not easy so
I'm very oh he's great it's just it's
very funny how you just would just not
Leslie answer and go that's amazing like
uh fair you know before fight it's you
know you're fighting another grown man
in your underwear in a steel cage so uh
could be fun to some people
yeah like somebody who has a pride flag
in their Studio Charlemagne it'd be fun
to summon them booty Bandits you can't
say that you have a pride flag in your
studio I don't give a [ __ ] dog that's
not even mine bro that's not even mine
that's this [ __ ] over here he points
with a girl and he just comes out of the
program director's office like an hour
later I want to apologize I think about
my words I've hurt
and I'm apologizing the Jewish Community
again I don't know why I didn't even
talk about them this time yeah for real
sounds like a good time for some people
for some people they love that that's
not me though man as soon as I could do
something else I will see you
have original really that was terrible
really for somebody as soon as I see
that I would do somebody a guy who
literally only talks about people's
penises
did you see uh Marsh
I'm going to tell you something right
now I'm not saying that the people the
people that are close to Brennan or do a
show with Brendan don't I'm not going to
say that they're not watching our show
okay because at this point
Papa
did you see this
this is a new one did you see this
remember what do we call out the most
about Brendan that he does the most
that he just completely talks while
other people are still talking okay
thanks for watching liking subscribing
and then you can head on over to
subscribe okay we're just gonna run it
we're running now baby yeah you're
talking about the page well yeah you're
cutting me off so it's very it's highly
annoying but
I like the crystalia will have none of
his [ __ ] which is kind of funny
and he's the fill-in for Theo at this
point because Theo's gone and yeah
thanks for watching liking subscribing
and then you can head on over here it's
gonna run it we're running now baby yeah
you're talking about the page well yeah
you're cutting me off so it's very it's
highly annoying but uh
he did it again he did it again no no
Adam Ray's wedding patreon people that's
in the comments Brandon's cutting people
off
I've had it they've had it that's in the
comments Brendan is cutting people off
it's okay it's one of his things that's
what I do it's what he does
it's one of his things that what he does
and by the way here's something else we
know our homeboy Eric be reading the
comments huh
yeah I didn't even think of that he kind
of you're better than this bud